once upon a time there was a great and  glorious King I had a vision a dream not  Palace Versailles  they will write stories about this place  but my fear those that hear it might not  believe it  I'm about to drag his country out of the  darkness into the light the building of  a scythe must be stopped he sees the  sign nothing else he's forgotten who  built this country he's hard to be a  king try being a king's brother for a  day  the men use their swords we use our  beauties take it off a conspiracy in  Paris was uncovered the Army has dissent  among its ranks let's see what we can do  to encourage them the great moment is  upon us which is what is that revolution  this was an act of sedition by traitor  one man cannot rule the land  I acted for France because I had false  seal the doors today you get the chops  hello Kate  boys have all the fun bow to your king